I have a question about leadership.
I'm a firefighter and some of the guys on my department have been pushing me to
step up
and put in for an opera officer's position and I'm honored but won't wear one.
When we were going to a call,
I was presented with an opportunity to lead and passed it up.
I didn't know what I was thinking.
I can't believe I did that.
Did I just lose credibility if I did?
Is there
Oh,
was to get back that back away,
right?
That's what he meant.
If I did,
is there a way to get that back?
Thanks.
Okay,
so first of all,
this is just a general rule.
If you want to lead,
always be ready to lead,
right?
Be ready to step up and make sure you're not stepping on people's toes as
always,
but be ready to lead.
And the way you do that,
as you think about you,
what do you do in certain situations,
you should always be thinking about that.
You should be thinking,
even if you're a trooper or a follower in a certain situation,
you should think,
okay,
well how would I lead?
What would I do right now?
What moves would I make?
What would I do if a contingency happened right now?
And what are the possible condenses that I could be looking at?
What are they?
And if you're thinking that as well as a
frontline guy,
when the opportunity pops up and just jump on it and boom,
there you go.
Then when it does happen,
of course you gotta stay detached because you want to make sure that you don't
lead too far.
You don't overstep your bounds and step on toes.
You've got to be careful of that.
So you need to live with that mindset and that will make you such a,
a better leader when the moment does come,
if you're always thinking about,
if you're always watching,
like you talked about earlier,
I'm watching the leader,
I'm seeing what they're doing,
I'm seeing what I might do differently.
I'm still supporting them.
I'm supporting you.
If you're in charge,
But I'm thinking I might,
I might do this.
And then you watch,
what would my,
what would the results of my decision had been compared to what they did?
So you can be thinking like leader even though you might not necessarily be in a
leadership position.
So live with that mindset.
That's what you need to do.
Now as far as you passing up the opportunity to lead,
which yes,
you're admitting wasn't air.
First of all,
I'll say they say probably it's probably not quite as obvious to everyone else
as it is to you.
In your mind you're thinking,
Oh man,
I blew it.
This was my chance.
And I bet the guys who went back from that call and didn't even think about it,
didn't even think about it again.
Most likely,
unless it was just some flake,
flagrant,
I don't want to lead.
I really already.
If you did that well then yeah,
people will get us there.
But if you just said,
if you just kind of backed away from a moment and people,
people might have realized it.
But anyways,
regardless of that,
you probably guess what I'm going to say.
Then what you gotta do is own it,
right?
You got to own it.
So when the opportunity presents itself to explain what happened and what went
wrong and what you did wrong,
right?
Not Making excuses,
but explain where you were weak,
you know,
so you say,
hey guys,
you know,
hey,
remember that last call I should have stepped up and I had the d had the wrong
mindset.
I wasn't ready to lead and I let him,
not only did I let you guys down,
I let myself down and I'm not going to let that happen again.
From now on,
I'm going to have leadership in the front of my mind.
That's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to be thinking about what needs to get done.
I'm gonna be thinking about contingencies and how I'm going to lead and I
promise the next time this opportunity comes up,
I'm going to be ready to lead.
So I'm sorry for letting you guys down and won't happen again.
Okay,
that's,
that's it.
Boom.
Get the mindset live and think as a leader,
regardless of what position you're actually in,
and then when they call you in the opera,
tunity presents itself.
Step up and lead.
Obviously that's your default mindset now.
Yes.
It seems obvious to me.
It is truly was it always like that?
Like even before,
it's that story that I've told over and over again about being on an oil rig and
coming up and guys not knowing where to go or everyone freezing and,
and me going,
okay,
let me just to step back and look around and make a call.
And when I did that,
that was it.
And so I clicked it clicked or I would say,
I guess I was thinking about it beforehand because I was,
you know,
observing my leaders and thinking about what they were doing and what I would do
differently in a certain situation.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Cause even in everyday life,
which is what I represent everyday life,
but you know how your life or girl,
whatever is like,
Hey,
well you know,
what's the dinner situation?
What do you want?
Oh I don't care.
Whenever you want.
You know,
that's a time where I,
I always feel this,
what this guy just asked,
you know,
I mean obviously it's nothing compared to his situation,
but they're like,
hey,
well,
you know,
what do you thinking for dinner kind of thing.
And I'm like,
Hey,
I don't,
I don't care.
And that's really how I feel.
I'm done kind of down for whatever kind of thing.
But that's not why,
that's not why she's asking me.
She wants me,
she wants me to make the decision mean and take to step up and lead,
step up and be like,
this is what we're having for dinner.
I'm going to go get her,
I'm going to make it or whatever.
That's what she wants.
And really those little dots,
those,
that situation comes up all the time.
Like you know the old that the Joe actually that's kind of like a joke.
You know,
when you ask the grill when a girl says,
or when you ask go,
Hey,
what do you want to eat?
And she says,
I don't,
I don't care.
Whatever.
And then you say,
okay,
we're going to go eat here.
And said,
hey,
I don't really like that.
See?
Yeah,
it's you gotta yeah,
I feel like this guy when I do that though,
that's the point there from now on,
you're going to step up and I'm going to do it yet,
but I want it to be my default is why,
you know like yours is like your default laying into,
oh this is what we're doing.
There you go.
Okay.
You know what?
I wish that was true with her when it did come to dinner.
Actually no,
it kind of is true cause I only to like three places to eat.
Yes.
And I go to one 80% of the time.
Yeah.
So the other 20% of the time,
so she says where you want to go?
I'm going to say that my restaurant.
Yeah,
we're going to Ragland's in ob.
That makes it harder though.
Right?
Does she like Ragman stuff?
She does.
Easier.
Yeah.
But and if she doesn't feel like it then she'll be like,
I don't really want to go there.
Okay,
cool.
Now it's on you.
I gave you my vote.
No,
you don't want to do that,
but I think you've still got to do it.
You still gotta make the decision you got to like,
cause in a way I'm in the same boat as your second scenario there.
Like if she's not in the room,
so then I just going to name my secondary restaurant.
Right?
There you go.
Just maybe she'll say yes asked.
Maybe she'll say no.
No.
That gotta be my default now though.
All right.
Step up and lead.
You know what I,
you know what I've gotta do?
I've got to prepare.
I've got to prepare myself.
I got to have like five options just ready to go on deck.
That's what I have.
Three slope
and they all come in the same order.
I must be really boring.
Hey,
you focus on what's important.
That's good.
Whenever my wife says,
you know,
well,
don't you ever want to try anything new?
I said,
nope.
Yeah,
I don't.
Yeah.
Speaking of which,
Darling,
you're my girl.
I'm not looking to try anything new.
That might happen with having the same thing there.
You happy?
Yes.
That's actually that I'm going to use that light right there,
but what do you do when the team wants to try something new?
All right,
let's rock and roll.
Let's do that.
All right.
Good tips.